ANSWERS, WHY IS THE LEFT TRYING
TO PREVENT YOU FROM ASKING THE
QUESTIONS?
A LAWYER AND FORMER OBAMA
CAMPAIGN ADVISOR JOINS US TODAY.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE BROADER
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE THE
COUNTRY IS GOING AND WHAT WE CAN
ABSORB, A FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED OVER THE WEEKEND.
I'VE WATCHED, ALL DAY, AS
AMERICANS HAVE DEFENDED FOREIGN
CITIZENS WHO ATTACKED AMERICAN
BORDER AGENTS AND SUGGESTED THAT
SOMEHOW THE AMERICANS ARE IN THE
WRONG WHEN FOREIGNERS WAITING
FOR AN THROW ROCKS AT THEM.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> YOU SHOWED SOME COMPELLING
FOOTAGE.
I THINK BOTH SIDES OF THIS
DEBATE NEED TO TAKE A DEEP
BREATH AND THINK ABOUT THEIR
POSITION.
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO CONTROL OUR BORDER
AND DECIDE WHO GETS IN.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, WE ALSO HAVE
TO USE RULE OF LAW WHEN WE
PROCESS PEOPLE WHO DO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO APPLY FOR POLITICAL
ASYLUM UNDER THE LAWS OF OUR
COUNTRY AND HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
THAT WHILE BEING IN A PEACEFUL
PLACE AND NOT UNDER THESE
SERIOUS SECURITY SITUATIONS THAT
THEY FACE.
HOLD ON.
>> Tucker: LET'S ADDRESS THE
FACTS OF THE CASE FOR A SECOND.
IF THEY WERE APPLYING FOR ASYLUM
THEN WHY DID THEY RUSH THE
BORDER CROSSING?
IS THAT ASYLUM APPLICATION LOOKS
LIKE?
>> NOT ALL OF THEM ARE GOING TO
MEET THE STANDARD FOR ASYLUM.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU SAY THAT
SOMEONE WHO WAVE THE FLAG OF A
FOREIGN COUNTRY AS HE RUSHES
YOUR BORDER STATION IS ELIGIBLE
FOR ASYLUM?
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
WOULD BE HOLDING THE FLAG WHEN
THE RUNNING FOR THAT COUNTRY BUT
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> Tucker: WHAT IF THEY TRY
AND BUM-RUSH THE BORDER AGENTS?
DOESN'T THAT IMMEDIATELY
DISQUALIFY THEM?
>> WE BOTH AGREE THAT THEY HAVE
NO RIGHT TO BUM-RUSH OUR BORDER
AND WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO USE
FORCE, NOT LETHAL FORCE, BUT A
NONLETHAL FORCE TO PREVENT THEM
FROM COMING ACROSS AND FOR THOSE
WHO THREW ROCKS, IT WAS RIGHT
FOR OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO
ARREST HIM AND EVEN TO USE
TEARGAS IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
NEEDED TO DO TO STOP THEM FROM
COMING ACROSS.
>> Tucker: WHY IS EVERYONE
LYING ABOUT THIS?
WHY IS THE DNC AND ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR THEM, ACOSTA
AND ALL THE BUFFOONS YOU SEE ON
TELEVISION, WHY ARE THEY
DEMANDING THAT WE NOT BELIEVE
OUR EYES, THERE'S NO CARAVAN,
THEY ARE TELLING US, THEY WOULD
NEVER HAVE THE BORDER, YOU ARE
RACIST IF YOU THINK THEY ARE
ATTACKING US, WHY ARE THEY LYING
TO US?
>> IF NOT FOR ME TO EXPLAIN WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING.
WHAT I WANT TO DO IS TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS A SENSIBLE
SOLUTION TO THIS, WHICH IS THE
COMPROMISE THAT WAS REACHED IN
OCTOBER BETWEEN THE U.S.
DOMESTIC THE REFUGEE AGENCY.
THEY STAY IN MEXICO, GIVEN
HOUSING, THEY CAN STAY THERE AND
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO APPLY FOR
POLITICAL ASYLUM IN THE U.S.
WHILE IN MEXICO AND DURING THAT
TIME THEY WILL BE PROCESSED
LEGALLY AND THEIR RIGHTS WILL BE
ADJUDICATED VIA OUR PROCESS.
AND IF THEY DON'T MEET THE
STANDARD, THEY CAN'T COME IN.
IN MANY OF THEM IN THE MEANTIME
WOULD LIKELY FIND JOBS IN MEXICO
OR GO HOME.
AND THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO BE REALLY
CLEAR, I HAVE TOTAL SYMPATHY FOR
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO COME HERE,
I'M GLAD TO BE A CITIZEN AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY WANT TO BE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT OUR INTERESTS?
HOW MANY PEOPLE CAN WE ABSORB --
BECAUSE NO ONE IS EVEN
PRETENDING THIS IS GOING TO MAKE
US A BETTER OR RICHER COMPANY.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE IS POORER
OBVIOUSLY.
AUTOMATION IS MAKING OUR OWN
JOBS GO AWAY.
HOW MANY PEOPLE CAN WE ACCEPT
BEFORE THIS COUNTRY REALLY
CHANGES -- IT'S A SERIOUS
QUESTION.
WHY IS NOBODY ASKING THE
QUESTION?
>> WE HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS OF
WHERE AMERICA IS.
IF YOU PAINTED TO BE THIS FEEBLE
STATE THAT CAN BARELY DEAL WITH
A COUPLE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
I THINK WE ARE STILL A
WEALTHIEST, STRONGEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD WE ALSO HAVE ACCEPTED
MANY IMMIGRANTS.
EVERYONE HERE IN LESS YOU ARE
NATIVE AMERICAN, YOU ARE AN
IMMIGRANT.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
320 MILLION PEOPLE.
I'VE GOT A BUNCH OF KIDS.
I PLAN TO DIE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND A KIND OF WANT TO KNOW WHAT
IT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE AND I
WANT A VOICE IN THAT.
SO WHAT CAN I EXPECT?
HOW MAY PEOPLE DO WE LET THEM
BEFORE IT'S ENOUGH?
>> WE ARE LETTING IN FAR FEWER
THIS YEAR AND LAST YEAR --
>> Tucker: WHAT'S A GOOD
NUMBER?
>> WE HAVE AN IMMIGRATION
PROBLEM.
WE HAVE TOO MANY PEOPLE HERE
THAT ARE HERE UNLAWFULLY.
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THAT
PROBLEM BUT WE CAN'T COMPLETELY
CUT OFF IMMIGRATION.
WE HAVE TO HAVE IMMIGRATION,
PROTECT OUR BORDERS BUT NOT
CLOSE OUR BORDERS.
>> Tucker: I WANT SOMEBODY TO
TELL ME, 50 YEARS FROM NOW
HERE'S WHAT AMERICA WILL LOOK
LIKE.
BUT NO ONE WANTS TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
YOU KNOW WHY.
>> THAT DEBATE NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE IN CONGRESS.
CONGRESS HAS PASSED AN
IMMIGRATION LAW THAT MAKES THESE
DECISIONS.
NUMBERS AND IT DECIDES HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE ARE GOING TO LET IN.
>> Tucker: NO ONE ELSE IS